Hey, so listen, this is not the most important
story, but we all need a little comedic relief
every once in a while. And last night
on Tucker Carlson's Fox News show,
guest after guest lost their connection. And I
don't know why, but I just found it hilarious.
I think part of it is the look on Tucker
Carlson, his face every time his guests would
lose connection. Now, I want to be really, really
clear. Texas is having power outages right now.
One of the guests who loses their Internet
connection is former Republican Governor Rick
Perry. And Tucker Carlson mentions him being
in Texas. Now, I don't know if the storms are
actually the reason Rick Perry loses Internet and
all of his guests, even the ones not in Texas,
we're losing connection. So it may have nothing
to do, but we are not making light of what is
happening in Texas right now. People without
power. OK, that's not what this is about.
I think what's funny is Tucker doing his confused
face every time it happens. So if you're only
listening, that will be an element that you
won't be able to observe unless you take a look
at the video versions of this. But let's jump
right into it. Here is former Texas governor,
former Trump administration secretary of Energy
Rick Perry losing his connection. And Tucker
tries to at least blame it on Rick's connection,
although I doubt whether that's what's going on.
Let's take a look.
So I. Love, Texas,
don't want to attack Texas, on the other hand,
the most basic responsibility of government,
you'd think, is to keep the power on, especially
when people need it to survive. They didn't. Why?
I should say that Rick Perry is in Texas,
it sounds like he was in space, but
he's not. He's in Texas. He has no power
that's being run, I think, on a generator.
He's proving the point that we're making.
Governor, we're going to put you on
hold for a second to see if we can
get the power back on in your state.
OK, so maybe it's the storms there,
but then incomes Florida Governor
Rhonda Santurce, a Republican governor
who was going on Tucker's show to brag about
how they're just opening it wide open in Florida
regardless of the virus, and he loses his
connection. Now, at this point, you can't blame
the power outages in Texas for Ron DeSantis
losing his connection. Can you take a look?
Ever says that out loud? I mean, how could
you ignore something that the data show?
Oh, I'm afraid we've lost Governor de Santos.
Can you hear me, Governor?
I can't hear oh, I'm sorry about that,
I can hear the governor, he cannot hear me. I
just want to say for the record that unlike as
in Texas tonight, I think the power is still on
in Florida. Fewer windmills in the state than
there are in Texas. So that's the good news. But
for some reason, the governor couldn't hear us.
We'll be back in just a moment. A lot going on.
I was having a grand old time watching these this
morning. It's also very poetic that a connection
was lost because these are two people, Rick Perry
and Ron de Santos, who lost their connections
with reality a long time ago. And I would actually
argue that this was Ron de Santos's best public
statement ever, just losing his connection and
being unable to say anything. He came off
looking way better than he normally does
when he's able to speak and notice Tucker Carlson
throwing in a dig at wind farms. They're sort of
laughing at windmills. And I think the idea there
is that Tucker wants to frame anybody relying on
wind farms can't possibly be keeping the power on
compared to burning fossil fuels, which I guess is
seen as manly and alpha among the American right.
No opportunity to attack clean energy that Tucker
Carlson won't avail himself of. And I mean,
listen, being Texas, I'd almost expect her to
blame the power outages or the loss of connection
on some migrant caravan approaching the border,
which seems to be a catch all anytime they need to
blame anybody for anything, maybe even antifa. But
many tech problems happening on Tucker
Carlson's program last night. I don't know why
I was laughing to myself this morning.
Just really got a kick out of that one.